bah je vais essayer d'aider nouvelle
semaine et puis c'est surtout des
chaussettes étanche là normalement elles
sont un peu épaisses donc ça devrait
amortir et ça doit éviter de me faire
une douleur au niveau du tibia
dans la famille chagnon les enfants sont
habitués à voir ludovic partir réaliser
des défis fous antoine déjà 4 iron man à
son actif a hérité de la philosophie de
son père on a une idée en tête après
11,2 on se dit pourquoi pas on y
réfléchit puis tu enfonces donc on évite
de se poser 15 mille questions et puis
c'est de vivre vivre ce qu'on a envie ce
qu'on pense vivre huit noël 25 kg de
vêtements et de nourriture voilà tout
l'équipement que ludovic champions va
devoir tirer avec sa luge pendant 300 km
sur le cercle polaire
l'idée c'est de changer au futur départ
de surtout surtout pas transpiré c'est
là c'est le risque numéro en fait parce
que transpire et donc c'est l'humilité
sur le corps dès qu'on s'arrête avec le
cif et -30 -40
vraiment un risque vital pour cinq jours
de course par moins 30 degrés rien n'est
laissé au hasard
il faut tout tester avant de partir même
le temps que met la nourriture avant de
jolis pour ces tests
ludovic seront deux fois par semaine
dans cette grande surface
direction le congélateur où il fait
moins 25 degrés là il court il dort il
se change l'objectif optimiser chaque
geste par grand froid
résultat du test du jour après 30
minutes
j'ai pu tester avec eux une main l'air
dans mon camp et il maintient souvent
donc souvent et très pratique pour quand
j'ai besoin de sentir la main par contre
si je reste longtemps j'ai froid en fait
le mieux c'est d'avoir rien du tout aidé
avec la chaleur de gonfler de durer
autant de monde autour de mon dans les
défis hors norme c'est le quotidien de
cet athlète son palmarès 70 ironman 900
km sur l'himalaya traversée de la vallée
de la mort par 50 cent degrés mais cette
fois ci il se lance sur le cercle
polaire pour collecter des fonds pour
deux associations vendômoise chacun peut
acheter un kilomètre ça coûte 10 euros
que c'est pas grand chose pour trois
sélections en forme pour acheter un deux
trois dix ont choisi ce qu'on veut sur
les 300 fois qu'ils sont disponibles et
les 3000 euros que ça va vous
représentez vont être reversés à deux
associations qui ont des maladies rares
donc la neurofibromatose est là
le syndrome de rett serein comme
toujours ludovic connaît son corps
parfaitement suivi par des médecins et
les biologistes ces défis sont étudiées
pour améliorer la recherche
il s'élancera le 23 février de rovaniemi
avec 14 autres concurrents pour cent
heures de course au nord de la finlande